Nice to meet you guys
Lovely to connect with you as well
I know Ratham I guess but I haven't met you all yeah
Sure, why don't we do a little bit of a one run of introduction so that
You don't get bored of seeing our faces or at least my face or for the next couple of minutes
And then we'll jump into the discussion if that's all right
Yeah
I'll kick things off
Much at this site. I look after the partnership ecosystem over here at short-term
I've been with the firm for what one and a half year at this point of time
Started out as a cybersecurity consultant then saw a little bit of you know transition throughout my career so far
and you know have
Tabled in different things have tried out
Development activities have tried out business consulting and then finally landed myself in data analytics and AI and have been here ever since
So that's a very quick run of myself
Okay, okay, I need to be done to Jayanthi
Jenny would you take it?
Yeah, hi, so now it's nice to virtually meet you
I'm Jayanthi I'm the business development manager and client partner for healthcare and life sciences at short hills
So been here a little over a year prior to this I
Was working with a federal contractor doing health policy research executing large-scale projects in
clinical quality assessment for
Centers of Disease Control and Prevention and CMS so federal clients, you know looking at how
How digitally ready they are for transformation and looking at clinical informatics assessment so
Applying that knowledge here to smaller business use cases
You know with partners and working together so interesting. So where are you based out of?
Currently I'm in Florida
so I
moved here about a month ago and then prior to that for about six years I was in Chicago and
Yeah, because you said well, so I kind of put relate to that, okay, and sorry
I didn't get him and show where you based out of I'm based out of Terry
Okay
Prathap you want to go next
I'm
Handing over the background to you so
Yeah, thank you. So yeah, I have been into medical writing for almost 15 years now
So I was I started my career back there in India then I moved to Canada
Was here was there for six or six years and then I've now moved to US and I'm working with just K as a
Interactor for medical writing and I'm mostly in oncology therapeutic area
My experience is varied in therapeutic areas
But yeah, here at GS camp with oncology
Well, I love you to connect with you over here on this digital platform
So I'm not sure how much Prathap has you know given you the brief about
We have prepared a little bit of a overview slide deck
just to give you a little bit of walkthrough of the things that we are working on and what we stand for at Shortills and
We'd love to share my screen walk you through it. Let me know once it pops up
Is it coming through it is is it possible for you to bring that in presentation?
Yeah, just
Yeah, so I'm not used to Google Meet. I'm much more used to
My stuff teams I just wanted to make sure it is popping up correct for every jump into presentation mode
It's working fine. Yeah, it's a bit bit small, but it's fine. Yeah
Yeah, you have to take it from phone. Sorry for that
So just a little bit of a
Overview of the things that we'll be looking into just a little bit of an introduction about us the company overview
Some of the things that we have been working on
If you it would be great if you can get a little bit of an input from your side
What what is the things that you are really interested in?
What is it that really excites you in terms of the agent work that's coming out in terms of AI generating a that's coming out and
then if you can walk you through the solution and
Then discuss the next steps
Okay, okay
So just a very quick overview of the organization
So short is we started out in
2018 so it's been more than eight years at this point of time
Since our initial operate, you know since we have founded up
We are primarily a generative AI agenda case services for so we understand about technology
We understand about so we have been playing around with the agent or generative AI piece
since the very
foundation years of our
You know since the very foundation years in 2018
and we have obviously just iterated on the learnings that we have gained over the couple of years and
Migrated on to the building a comprehensive suite for gender TV as well as the latest kid on the block that is agent aki
We have partners with all the major hyper scalers whether you're looking at data breaks Microsoft AWS
Google IP into the world. So we work together with all of these partners
you know in the field of data and AI to
Create custom solutions that help our customers address their specific requirements
So at this point of time, I just want to take a step back and you know
Understand a little bit about or get your input about how your experience with the AI has been so far
for example for myself when I started out with
More recently when we were experimenting with the AI the couple of things that we see we saw were you know
AI hallucinating the hell out of any document that we pumped to it
generating fictitious reports generating fictitious references and you know
Generally screwing things up and then us having to go through each and every line item just trying to find out
Hey, where did we actually go wrong and don't even get me started about the
Tables or the figures that we pop in for example numbers and AI just never used to get along
So these were couple of the issues that we faced
How far have you been along in your age or me? Have you faced similar issues?
Are you facing similar issues right now?
Would you be comfortable with sharing any such?
Yeah, so I don't know it's a lot of confidential info
So I don't know how much I can share but I'll just try to be as broad as I can
Is I asked you know if he could just provide me of what exactly are we gonna talk about so I
Could bear myself better, but this is like impromptu. So, you know, but yeah, we are using AI and I think every
Organization in the world today is trying to but confidentiality
Maintainance because there's a lot of confidential data that we deal with you know every day
So how do you guys handle that and definitely the issues that you mentioned that you know
Documents going hay where and you know everything that we expected we could have done
Manual manually, you know things much better than what AI is doing. So how much?
Review is actually needed and in place of you know reducing our time
Is it you know doubling because we're doing it over again, you know, so those those those issues how how much you know?
Is it that you guys are able to work on those things and just
Yeah, these are some issues that we've been facing and how do you maintain confidentiality if there's patient data?
so yeah, got it
So if you're looking at specifically patient data one of the things that we found to be really helpful was
masking the
So we created a masking solution. So what happens is I feed it for example
I am looking at any PHI information that has been provided to me
So I feed that to my internal solution what it does is it does not call on any external AI
It goes through the document that is already provided and runs a back in smaller
what is known as a small language model over there and
It masks all of the personally identifiable information
So that the health information is retained which can be passed forward for AI
You know other sort of analytics that can be done for it
But whatever personal information was there for example social security number for US citizens
addresses phone numbers names
Parents names, you know any other
Personal identifiable information that is completely masked out or blacked out or grayed out and all the relevant health information
Which might be required for any sort of your your medical writing purposes or for your other analytics that you are running on top
But for any of the drugs that you're on any of the trial study of conducting that information
Sorry for interrupting before I lose the chain thoughts whom are you saying it is masked for the regulatory bodies for?
for you, not for passing on to AI.
Okay.
So you can obviously use it for.
And if there is analysis that needs to be done based on that information, how do you do that?
Because it's, it's not coming to the AI, it's masked, right?
So how will you analyze that information?
So what happens is, for example, I am Himachu.
The way in which the masking is done is a couple of different ways in which you can go about doing that.
One of the ways is you can actually create out.
The other one is you can mask it with a code name which is stored within your internal database.
And nobody apart from you has access to that database.
So what happens is Himachu Yadav is replaced with patient one.
So here's the address.
My address is replaced with address 01.
01 is obviously denoting the patient number.
Patient 01, address 01.
And similarly, all of those things are masked with a unique identifier such as this.
It can be patient 01.
It can be any sort of unique number that you are willing to go forward with.
So this is one of the ways that we make that.
So if you want us to mask the data and then provide to AI,
or this masking can also be done using AI.
This is another task added, right, masking?
So it can be done via AI or without AI.
Without AI is one thing that we have seen has been much more something of a beneficial aspect that companies are looking at.
The simple reason being, if you have to mask any sort of content using AI itself,
that defeats the purpose.
So organizations what they are going forward with is deploying a smaller model.
So what this model looks like is it will be deployed within your system.
For example, it will be installed on your laptop and it can function as a simple application.
For example, as your word application, you just upload relevant document over there,
and you specify how you want to mask that information.
And then it gives you or throws out a PDF output for you.
Hey, this is the masked report.
So this is just one of the solutions that we crafted up.
Another solution that we were focusing on, or one that we have been focusing most of our energies on,
is actually for the medical writing piece.
Hey, you're looking at different modules.
Module one to five for your ECGD document, ECGD dossier submission.
How can we ensure that this entire process, this entire ECGD dossier creation can be accelerated for the medical writers?
So we decided to focus our energies on CSRs to come up as a showcase of our capabilities.
Hey, this is something that we can do.
And what we decided we saw from the existing products on the market is,
people tend to consider or people would try to consider medical writers as prompt engineers,
which is not really the core task that you are interested in,
or you want to devote any amount of your energy towards.
You want to get a report.
Hey, I will provide you with the documents.
You generate a report to me.
I'll review it and then I'll submit it forward.
So this is the core area that you want to work in.
You don't want to play around with, hey, maybe this prompt will generate the correct CSR report for me,
or maybe this prompt will generate at least 50, 60% relevant CSR for me,
or maybe this prompt will generate 70, 80% relevant CSR for me for that particular therapeutic area.
So we did not want to play around with that.
What we wanted to do was create a seamless module,
which ensures that medical writers can go towards CSR creation within as few clicks as possible and make it as intuitive as possible.
So I'll come to the video in a couple of minutes.
But this is what we were focusing on.
This is what we were considering.
Any questions for us so far?
What is the source that you need for creation of the CSR?
I'm sorry?
What are the sources that you need for generating the CSR?
So we are looking at different documentation that would be required.
For example, CTPs, TLFs, you want a statistical and an unexplained,
or if you are looking at whatever source or information that you generally use to create those CSR reports,
those similar reports will be used by us.
So you will need all of them, right?
So what if something gets changed in the middle?
So that is where the version control comes in.
Will you need the updated sources from us again?
Or because we have provided the sources, now they will be updated because you have those sources already there with you.
Will they be updated automatically or will you need the new updated sources?
So it depends on how you want to configure the system.
For example, you might be using VivaVol for right now, for your existing document management requirements.
So what happens is maybe you created the initial CSR using the first set of documents that you received on maybe say 1st of October.
Now, as of 6th of October, you received an updated TLFI.
That's what I'm asking.
So what will happen is as soon as you update the TLFI, what will happen is a response will be triggered to the system.
Hey, there has been a change.
You will configure that accordingly so that whenever such a change happens, it is reflected back into this particular R system.
And that automatically triggers the next step.
Or you can configure it.
Hey, now I want you to go ahead.
I confirm that this is the new TLFI report and you should go ahead and create the new CSR report for me.
So that just want to jump in Sonal and say one more thing.
The benefit in working with us too is we can really customize and personalize it to the workflows that you're following.
So of course we follow a standard template and process based on how we know the overarching CSR generation and ECTD module prep works for each organization.
So we understand that it's different from one group or team to the other.
So what Hemantji just described is the initial approach that we can take based on conversations, but of course depending on the level of privacy and security that you need, that can be adopted or adapted.
Okay, thanks for clarifying.
Alright, hope that clears up your query.
Yeah, I mean you're saying that I will still have to give a prompt again that there are new sources.
So whenever the sources are updated, what I'm trying to ask is will your, what do you say agent, AI agent, will that auto once they have been once you have TLFs from us.
Now that the others are updated.
So will it generate a new CSR based on the updated TLFs or will you want us to provide new TLFs?
So just to clarify here, yeah, I agree just to clarify here, it depends on how much of the solution you adapt and what levels of for example, once you've provided the sources and it's generated a CSR, which would be phase one, we'd start with the CSR generation engine.
And then we can scale the solution to the upstream and downstream documents. So if you want to focus on generating those TLFs within part of, you know, the platform solution that we work to build together with you, we can do that so that when you're ready to update the TLFs you're
working within one system so you're not having to go back and forth between different things to update the sources.
The other added or the other benefit is if you, because this would work as sort of a layer on top of your existing systems. If you wanted to keep those origin sources the same the TLFs are coming from the same data management system and wouldn't want to change that that's also a possibility so it can be integrated in such a way that we're not adding more manual tasks to your overall workflow.
Interesting. Okay.
All right.
So this is how we are visualizing it.
This looks at the other features that we are, you know, this looks at the complete ECD module that we are looking at clinical from clinical study reports to IDs to ICS to STPs to TLFs.
Sorry if you go back to one sec. So on the right, inclement incremental platform capability. That's what we were talking about. So, you know, we can start with those, you know, start with the CSR generation and then depending on whatever source or area has the next highest
benefit or value in transforming using the platform we can focus on that next. So this is just a layout of the deliverables, you know, based on what we know typically happens and which direction to scale in but if you wanted to prioritize something else we could look at how to
start to integrate that piece next.
Any questions?
Sorry.
All right, good.
So I'll.
take you through the solution in action
so that you can see it and, you know,
understand a little bit more about how we are visualizing
the solution and how we visualize the answer
to the problem of AI within medical writing.
Hey, is the audio coming through?
Mm-hmm.
All right, cool.
Yeah, I'm actually sorry the audio is not.
Sonal, can you hear it?
I don't think I can hear it.
Well, I don't have audio.
No, the video is not having an audio.
Ah.
So Sonal, I am also having the similar problem
that you were having.
I'm having some facing issues with the audio
not coming through.
Yeah.
I have it handy with you
if it is popping through for you.
Uhhh, damn.